bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce samedi c'est le grand
soir pour le football français
lyon bordeaux marseille paris lens
toulouse
de nombreuses villes vont vivre 90
minutes de suspense ambiance à moins
d'une heure de l'événement dans un
instant
ségolène royal se lance officiellement à
la conquête du parti socialiste à six
mois du congrès de reims qui sont ces
soutiens quel est son projet comment
éviter l'affrontement
la guerre des chefs ségolène royal nous
expliquera sa méthode ce soir elle est
l'invitée de ce journal
les conséquences du tremblement de terre
sont toujours aussi dramatique en chine
glissements de terrain routes coupées
nos équipes ont pu se rendre pour la
première fois au coeur du drame
images et témoignages qui vous le verrez
vont nous permettre de mieux comprendre
l'ampleur du désastre
c'est le grand format de ce samedi tout
autre chose avec la question qu'ont ceux
du jour est il intéressant d'acheter sa
voiture sur internet
de plus en plus de français franchissent
le pas un choix économique mais
attention une nouvelle fois au piège de
la toile enfin cela faisait neuf ans que
son public français l'attendait tous ne
pouvaient pas se rendre à las vegas pour
suivre leur idole céline dion est de
retour elle sera dès lundi en concert à
paris nous équipons pu la rencontrer
hier et rassurez-vous le show promet
d'être grandiose
ils sont des milliers de supporters qui
en ce moment même se rendre au stade un
peu partout en france et une grande
partie d'entre eux retiennent leur
souffle
certains rêves de titre ils sont alors
lyonnais ou bordelais d'autres
s'interrogent leur équipe sera t-elle
condamné à jouer l'an prochain en ligue
2 c'est le cas des supporters lensois un
match à double enjeu face à bordeaux on
prend la direction de lens et on
retrouve marié annemasse et patrick bur
storm
ça donne à fond à fond noir le bordeaux
jusqu'à la lie à choix 3 autour du stade
bollaert ohis les couleurs et à lens pas
question de faire pâle figure pour les
sang et or c'est ce soir ou jamais il va
falloir donner de la voix y a pas de
numéro 12 à l'ancien de viol le douzième
homme c'est nous tous publics et le
douzième homme pour le moment il
s'échauffe avec le 13e le 14e et tous
les autres et même les supporters de
l'équipe adverse pour cette dernière
journée de championnat
il y en a pour tout le monde je suis
passé détiennent j'espère que les
lillois mon père ce soir et ils seront
plus de 40000 ce soir au stade pour un
match à guichets fermés avec chacun son
analyse des enjeux et de l'avenir du
club
alors on récapitule il faut qu'on gagne
que griffe herbe
un match nul pour nous ils vont gagner
ce soir et 20 semaines tenir même aussi
malheureusement ils descendent dans les
jeux 2 on sera toujours derrière eux il
faut gagner sinon c'est la fin
voilà allez lens à quelques minutes du
coup d'envoi le douzième homme révise
ses classiques qui commence à faire la
fête avant et toujours cette prix après
on verra bien
autre lieu autre suspense ce soir à
toulouse d'abord qui reçoit valenciennes
on craint également la descente en ligue
2 pour cette dernière journée
la défaite est interdite situation
identique pour le paris saint germain
qui pour la première fois depuis 20 ans
joue son maintien parmi l'élite et tout
cela va se dérouler à sochaux on
retrouve sur place franck gêne au zoo
bonsoir franck c'est un match en tout
cas placé ce soir sous haute sécurité et
également oui mon sens à l'orangé un
petit peu mieux du mal à vous entendre
parce que l'ambiance est en train de
monter si au stade bonal de sochaux mais
c'est effectivement un match à hauts
risques classées à haut risque par les
autorités un chiffre parlant il ya mille
supporters du paris saint germain qui
sont attendus et 500 policiers qui ont
été déployés les supporteurs sont
arrivés très tôt ils ont investi les
bars du centre-ville ici les ont animés
on redouter des incidents il a bien eu
quelques échauffourées mais pour
l'instant aucune interpellation selon la
préfecture
ses supporters maintenant vont être
conduits à l'intérieur du stade où ils
seront encadrés par une quarantaine de
stadiers l'état dès qu'on a vu répéter
tout à l'heure des mouvements pour
éviter d envahissement de terrain
un des leaders de la tribune des
boulogne boys celle du paris saint
germain nous disait il ya quelques
minutes c'est l'union sacrée et l'union
sacrée derrière les joueurs l'union
sacrée derrière les dirigeants et le
club
en attendant le résultat et s'il est
négatif et bien sa tenue sa clé c'est
une sacrée pourrait voler en éclats le
paris saint-germain
va-t-il se maintenir en ligue 1 réponse
ici au stade bonal de sochaux dans un
petit peu plus de deux heures si franck
enfin prononcé sur la direction de lyon
place bellecour où les supporters
pourront suivre le match sur écran géant
dany sébastien vous êtes sur place
bonsoir les lyonnais qui rêve ce soir
d'un septième titre consécutif
oui bonsoir laurent on attend environ
5000 personnes ici sur la place
bellecour et il flotte dans la ville
comme un parfum de finale
effectivement ces dernières années les
supporters s'étaient habitués à voir
leurs équipes championnes bien avant la
fin du championnat
cette année il n'en est rien et ce n'est
pas plus mal nous disait tout à l'heure
des supporters rencontrés notamment dans
la boutique de noël ce n'est pas plus
mal comme si on jouait un petit peu à se
faire peur comme si on avait oublié le
frisson ces dernières années qu'on était
heureux de le retrouver
alors heureux de le retrouver évidemment
à condition qu'à l'arrivée l'équipe soit
sacrée championne pour ça il va falloir
attendre la fin du match
si c'est le cas évidemment la fête se
prolongera tard dans la nuit ce soir
elle se prolongera aussi peut-être
demain sans doute vous savez dans les
milieux du sport on est un peu
superstitieux alors officiellement rien
n'est prévu demain en cas de septième
titre mais officieusement il est fort à
parier que l'hôtel de ville ouvrirait
grand ses portes à l'équipe et à son
trophée pour qu'elle puisse le présenter
à ses supporteurs merci denis voilà pour
le football résultats analyses et
commentaires dès demain 12h dans france
de foot
le prix du gazole est toujours au coeur
de la colère des marins pêcheurs colère
qui s'exprime encore aujourd'hui dans le
port des minimes à la rochelle
le port est bloqué tout comme celui du
croisic et de la turballe en loire
atlantique 1 un mouvement qui s'étend
donc progressivement on fait le point ce
soir avec un i phone signé drôle de fête
du nautisme ce week end à saint gilles
croix de vie en vendée
aucun marin ne prend la mer depuis ce
matin les pêcheurs sont en grève et
bloquent le port de plaisance
ils demandent des aides au gouvernement
pour faire face à la hausse du gasoil
qu'il paie aujourd'hui 70 centimes
on attend qu'il y ait une aide que j'ai
quelque chose que les gasoils des gens
qui se prennent qu'il arrête de monter
c'est le gasoil il continue la montée
qui nous diminue nos charges vous
quelque chose quoi au moins jusqu'à nous
la au point où on en est on peut plus
aller pêcher le prix du poisson demande
pour crier on leur vend le même prix il
y avait un temps le poisson a jamais
vous mentez sous criée on va au
supermarché ou dans les poissonneries sa
triple voire voire plus depuis trois
jours on ne rentre pas non plus dans le
vieux port de la rochelle
les bateaux de pêche docte également le
port des minimes les 500 plaisanciers du
week end ne peuvent entrer ou sortir que
la nuit c'est tellement facile de
bloquer tout le monde
enfin c'est comme ça de l'autre côté bon
faut comprendre que c'est leur cash
compte aussi c'est leur gagne pain hier
soir les pêcheurs ont même sensibilisé à
l'art cause les touristes venus sur
l'île de ré leur mouvement commencé le
10 mai s'étend aujourd'hui de la
charente maritime à la loire atlantique
les ports bretons sont en attente
une réunion est prévue mercredi au
ministère de la pêche
d'ici là les actions devraient continuer
les pêcheurs français se sentent
d'étrangler dans l'actualité également
parlons de ces braquages à répétition de
bijouterie cette semaine encore à clichy
dans les hauts-de-seine
une fusillade a eu lieu entre policiers
et malfaiteurs dans le centre-ville des
attaques qui se sont multipliées dans
les quartiers populaires de la capitale
où on la passe vendôme des hold up de
plus en plus violents explications
vincent fichman emmanuel maurel
l'agression da2 jeudi en fin de matinée
une femme apparemment seul sonne à la
porte de la bijouterie les poules du
patron ne soupçonne rien et ouvre la
porte
son mari va conclure est tout de suite
les trois idées qui se trouvent des
arias qui rentre là tout de suite en est
la dame les parties et d'un seul coup
elle sortait pistolet ensuite il a dit
mettez vous partez à ne bougeait pas ne
priez pas le braquage durera quelques
minutes
montant du butin selon le propriétaire
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'euros
la phénomène en hausse pour le prouver
le bijoutier nous conduit trois cents
mètres plus loin chez un ami lui aussi
dans le métier est lui aussi victime
c'était il ya quelques mois c'est pareil
ayhan d'amc essonne après bon et
bloquent la porte et 3,3 à perth en iran
depuis le commerçant croit avoir trouvé
une solution
je n'ai fait plus plaidant pour ne pas
prendre trop trop de risques trop de
risques parce que lens à laquelle mon ca
coute trés trés chiens dont sa boutique
pas de caméra pas de sas de sécurité
une proie facile dans ce quartier
populaire de paris
on dénombre une petite dizaine
d'attaquants quelques semaines les
braqueurs seraient jeunes et bien
organisés ils ont choisi avec des
vendeurs à la sauvette qui doivent
écouler la marchandise sur le sur la
plus simple ce n'est pas une marchandise
extrêmement cher au dessus de
marchandises que tout le monde peut
acheter pour dissuader les braqueurs
la préfecture de police de paris vient
de mettre en place un nouveau système de
surveillance spécifique ass et
bijouterie mardi une fillette de 5 ans a
trouvé la mort en chutant
accidentellement du 7e étage de
l'appartement familial à bobigny un
drame qui illustre un vrai problème de
société il n'y a pas que la vigilance
des parents qui concernait se sont
également vous allez le voir les normes
de sécurité de nos fenêtres qui sont
souvent inadaptés
reportage jenny briffa eric de l'agneau
ce jour là il ne pleuvait pas au
contraire il faisait très beau
le petit thomas ne s'en souvient pas
mais il est tombé par la fenêtre comme
il y avait un grand soleil elle n'était
pas fermée vous avez six mois et ne
marchait pas encore et donc comme vous
pouvez voir les radiateurs
même la fenêtre avec un garde-fou de
s'agripper et malheureusement berlin
fait voilà c'est ce qui s'est passé
ensuite il a basculé de l'autre côté
donc ça y est vous l'avez laissée sans
surveillance combien de temps un espace
de temps très court ses vingt dix vingt
trente secondes quelques secondes
d'inattention 15 mètres de chute à 3 ans
thomas est un miraculé
chaque année 200 enfants se défenestre
accidentellement 30 ans meurt et le
problème préoccupe peu les appartements
sont très peu sécurisé les normes
laxistes en france les gardes du corps
font 90 cm aux etats unis ils sont 20 cm
plus haut donc l'enfant soit en sécurité
il faudrait dans l'idéal c'est ce que
nous avons montré nous sur la base des
serres go no milk effectué auprès
d'enfants de moins de 6 ans que les
garde-corps soit au minimum à 10 et on a
montré qu'un enfant de moins de 6 ans
peut franchir jusqu'à 1 mètre 20 avec un
point d'appui
pire encore les règlements de
copropriété interdit souvent aux parents
de sécuriser leurs fenêtres pour des
raisons esthétiques pour interdire ces
faits close il faudrait que la
réglementation générale de l'urbanisme
de l'habitat soit modifié le dr meijer
lui attend depuis de longues années que
le code de l'urbanisme évolue lui même
reçoit chaque week end ensoleillé 2 à 3
enfants défenestré dans cette salle
d'anesthésier les enfants n'ont qu'une
peur du vide
non absolument pas la notion du danger
comme ils ne ressentent pas le danger
non pas le
réflexe de poser les mains ou les pieds
au moment d'une chute et donc la plupart
du temps il tombe directement sur la
tête
les accidents par défenestration sont
plus fréquents que ce par noyade dans
les piscines
et pourtant la réglementation est bien
plus longue à évoluer à l'étranger
maintenant le grand format ce samedi
nous emmène au coeur du drame que la
chine est en train de vivre alors qu'une
nouvelle secousse d'une magnitude de 6
sur l'échelle de richter a frappé la
province du sichuan
ce soir notre équipe a pu se rendre pour
la première fois au plus près de
l'épicentre du séisme
elle vous fait découvrir une de ces
villes dévastées
une parmi des dizaines d'autres un
document réalisé par sam à saoula et
tristan le bras regardez le tableau noir
de radhouane ben ali s'est transformé en
tombeau pour un millier d'adolescents et
leurs professeurs
malgré l'acharnement des sauveteurs ce
ne sont que des corps sans vie qui sont
sortis cinq jours après le séisme une
classe entière vient d'être dégagée
l'affolement d'un père à la recherche de
sa fille de 17 ans à défaut de la savoir
vivante
il veut voir son corps comme lui des
dizaines de parents se sont précipités
c'est un garçon ou une fille un autre
corps arrive sur la piste d'athlétisme
transformé en morgue
l'homme a cours à nouveau ce n'est pas
sa fille mais c'est la même tragédie au
milieu des linceuls
les cérémonies funéraires s'enchaînent
pour tous ces parents c'est le pire qui
vient de leur arriver dans un pays qui
leur a imposé d'avoir un seul et unique
enfant on a répondu à l'appel du pays en
ayant un seul enfant et maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
n'a plus de 40 ans on aura plus
d'enfants qui s'occupera de nous quand
on sera vieux rat noir très proche de
l'épicentre n'est qu'un enchevêtrement
de ruines un cimetière à ciel ouvert
partout des cadavres que personne ne
vient chercher il n'y a parfois plus
personne pour les réclamer la ville de
70000 habitants a été décimée ici
c'était le jardin d'enfants jour et nuit
des secouristes combattent corps à corps
avec les amas de béton
épaulé par une armée chinoise en ordre
de bataille
on n'a pas trouvé de survivants passé 72
heures ces critiques
oui on va continuer à chercher au pied
de l'usiné de moteurs à coller à la mine
de charbon un camp de survivants tous
ils étaient employés
malgré l'odeur insoutenable ils se sont
installés là où donc pourrions nous
aller demande-t-il les cadavres de leurs
collègues existe encore dans l'usiné
ce couple vit aussi de l'usiné de la
mine détruites
leur maison est pulvérisé mais ils
prennent le risque de s'aventurer sur
ces décombres
ils sont venus chercher ce qui était
jadis le placard de leur cuisine je
cherche les shows il peut encore
utiliser ça lorsqu'on n'a plus rien pas
de complaintes ils sont vivants la femme
a été sauvée après être restées coincées
7 heures quand ça a tremblé rester là et
j'ai attendu des deux parce que tout le
monde c'est d'abord précipité à l'école
puis mon frère est venu et j'ai réussi à
grimper à l'extérieur à la nuit tombée
rannou en continue à chasser les démons
il faut désinfecter des camps les
épidémies kate c'est sur une place
dégagé qu'une cité de tendre s'est
dressée pour reloger ceux qui ne sont
pas partis même les maisons restées
debout sont encore dangereuse les
répliques sont régulières
autour du groupe électrogène une forêt
de portable le réseau marche enfin et
c'est par lui karibe les bonnes et des
mauvaises nouvelles
je suis toujours sans nouvelles d'une
partie de ma famille ce téléphone
c'est notre seul bien possible
aujourd'hui contre toute attente dans la
nuit noire
un feu d'artifice éclatent ce n'est pas
un accident mais un hommage des
habitants aux militaires qu'ils
poursuivent sans relâche les recherches
sous les projecteurs les fouilles
continuent malgré la fatigue les
familles ne quittent pas les lieux
encore un corps il y déposer quelques
mètres plus loin sur un bout de trottoir
seul presque dans l'indifférence dans la
seine est banal ce jeune homme pleure
son épouse son père s'occupe du rituel
des vêtements personnels de l'argent de
l'encens tout ce qui doit accompagner la
défunte dans son dernier voyage
elle était enceinte de six mois
on l'a retrouvé dans la maison jean à
deux secondes près elle aurait survécu
une femme enceinte au petit matin
trannoy on n'est pas sorti du cauchemar
du renfort est arrivée des russes avec
leur chien
la russie est un des rares pays dont le
régime chinois a accepté l'envoi de son
courrier il aurait pu arriver en trois
heures mais pékin en a décidé autrement
malgré tout on peut encore retrouver des
survivants
bon iver dans d'autres pays on en a
retrouvé au bout de sept jours cet homme
veut en tout cas y croire aux policiers
ils brandissent un sms et appels au
secours de son neveu le message n'est
arrivé qu'hier à cause de la panne de
réseau à l'école de donc si on a fini de
sortir les cadavres
mais ses parents n'ont pas retrouvé
leurs enfants un espoir pour eux qu'ils
étaient et transportés dans l'évacuation
des blessés pour réaliser l'ampleur du
drame que vivent les chinois il faut
comprendre que la situation de rouen qui
se répète en ce moment même dans des
dizaines d'autres localités
cinq jours après on peut véritablement
parler d'une des pires catastrophes dans
l'histoire de la chine
voilà pour ce document en birmanie après
le passage du cyclone meurtrier la junte
freine toujours l'aide humanitaire en
provenance de l'étranger exemple
aujourd'hui un bâtiment de la marine
nationale française le mistral est
arrivé au large des côtes birmanes avec
à son bord des médicaments et des vivres
mais aucun accord n'a été trouvé sur la
livraison de son chargement humanitaire
le représentant de la birmanie à l'onu a
ainsi reproché à la france d'envoyer je
cite un navire de guerre à l'étranger
enfin françois fillon et est au pérou
ces dernières heures pour le sommet
union européenne-amérique latine un
sommet en marge duquel il a rencontré ou
de chavez afin d'évoquer le sort
d'ingrid betancourt françois fillon a
déclaré je cite vouloir négliger aucune
piste pour sa libération
on revient en france avec une phrase
politique attendu certes mais qui en a
surpris plus d'un question peut-être de
timing une phrase qui officialise en
tout cas le lancement de la campagne de
ségolène royal pour le poste de premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
c'était hier soir devant les militants à
paris on les écoute avant de retrouver
ségolène royal sur ce ce plutôt si les
militants en décide ainsi
et s'il estime utiles pour le ps
j'accepterai avec joie et détermination
d'assumer cette belle mission de chef du
parti csu
bonsoir c'est quand même horaire merci
avec nous alors cette fois c'est fait
vous êtes donc candidate au poste de
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
oui vous savez cette phrase a été
prononcée au terme d'une longue
intervention de trois quarts d'heure
écolo avec des militants oui comme je
l'avais dit j'avais lancé une étape de
consultation participative et je faisais
hier la synthèse de cette consultation
et en rendant des comptes sur les
engagements que j'avais pris j'ai dit en
effet très clairement les conséquences
que j'en tirais voilà donc je prends que
les choses sont à la fois simple elles
sont mûrement réfléchies
elle s'adresse aussi à une conception du
parti socialiste à la prise de
conscience aussi de la gravité de la
situation en france aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est ça met un moment historique
pour un congrès toriques prêt à voir
avec la montée en puissance de bertrand
delanoë la sortie de son livre
prochainement n'est pas un agenda
précipiter non contraire c'est l'agenda
que je m'étais fixés d'abord la
réflexion après l'élection
présidentielle pour en tirer les leçons
j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai beaucoup
changé aussi depuis cette élection j'ai
vu ce qui avait fonctionné ce qui
n'avait pas été compris des français
il ya aussi un an que la droite est au
pouvoir que les français se demandent si
la politique encore un sens c'est
pourquoi la la mission historique du
parti socialiste lors du prochain
congrès au mois de novembre prochain
sera de démontrer à nouveau qu'une autre
politique est possible et lui faut un
leader au parti socialiste
c'est ce que en tout cas les militants
m'ont dit est dit aujourd'hui dans le
parti socialiste et c'est pour ça aussi
que je veux leur répondre en toute
clarté et finalement sincèrement ya pas
trop de candidats au parti socialiste
1 2 3 4 mais là on a l'impression qu'ils
se multiplient
oui je pense qu'il faut savoir maîtriser
les choses ça peut surprendre un peu les
français bout du compte vous savez les
militants vont choisir
et puis la question centrale qui se pose
et qui va se poser dans ce texte sans
dans ce projet que sur lequel je
travaille maintenant avec une équipe
avec aussi des responsables socialistes
d'en dans 25 départements j'espère
qu'ils seront plus nombreux
bientôt c'est de savoir comment dans le
monde tel que nous vivons aujourd'hui où
la précarité
augmente où les inégalités n'ont jamais
eu était aussi criante où le capitalisme
perd la tête ou les valeurs financières
l'emportent sur les valeurs humaines
dans socialisme il ya social il n'y a
aucune raison de laisser broyer le
social par l'économique ou devant la
question est de savoir aussi si vous
voulez ce qui va être au coeur du projet
c'est la question suivante quels sont
les droits et les devoirs qu'il faut
aujourd'hui redéfinir pour que les
responsables politiques
la société et les individus puissent
avoir les mêmes droits pour réussir leur
vie au fond comment faire en sorte que
chacun puisse rêver à un avenir meilleur
c'est dans une deux de ses contributions
à jeudi mais finalement j'ai pas peur de
l'avenir c'est presque pire j'ai peur de
ne pas avoir d'avenir et bien moi je
pense que le rôle de la politique et le
rôle des socialistes c'est de dire à
chaque homme et chaque femme - chaque
enfant qui n'est qu'il peut avoir un
espoir d'un avenir meilleur alors voilà
pour quelques éléments de votre
programme en tout cas auprès des
militants on va écouter les deux
premières réactions au sein de votre
propre camp au sein du parti socialiste
on écoute on est en train de transformer
le parti socialiste en une pétaudière
on ne respecte ni les règles ni le
calendrier ni les militants nous n'avons
pas intérêt dans le congrès de 2008
une confrontation entre ce qu'on appelle
les présidentiables entre ségolène royal
et bertrand delanoë et que ce n'est pas
de ça dont le parti socialiste a besoin
qui ne doit pas désigné son candidat et
présentiel ou le prêt désigné dès 2008
ségolène royal est ce que vous n'avez
pas l'impression qu'il ya une tendance
on va dire oh oh tout sauf ségolène
comme vous l'avez vécu un petit peu
pendant la campagne électorale oui ou
non sincèrement
écoutez moi je crois que si un jour je
suis à la tête du parti socialiste si
les militants me m'accorde cette
confiance et me donne cette joie et
cette lourde tâche
eh bien les responsables socialistes ne
pourront plus s'exprimer de façon
désobligeante ou violentes à l'égard
d'autres socialistes pourquoi comment
vous allez faire pour faire peur tout
seul et il y aura mais il y aura des
règles qui seront appliquées il y aura
des droits et des devoirs il y aura des
sanctions
parce que je pense que nous avons une
responsabilité commune nous socialistes
de construire un parti fort
un pari fou ni un parti où l'on se
respecte ses adversaires non c'est pas
une question c'est pas une question de
se faire taire c'est de faire taire les
uns et les autres une question de la
qualité dans l'expression du respect
dans l'expression je crois que les
militants aujourd'hui attendre attend
d'être respecté et s'il y avait un mot à
retenir c'est le sens de ma démarche
aujourd'hui
ensuite les militants vont choisir donc
les choses seront très simples mais je
crois que chaque fois qu'un socialiste
s'exprime il doit d'abord penser à la
france et aux français aujourd'hui ce
qui fait peur aux français c'est une
mondialisation mal maîtrisée c'est
l'émergence de grands continents à
l'égard desquels la france ne trouve
plus sa place c'est une identité
française qui est bousculé par la peur
de l'autre et nous avons tellement de
travail à faire ensemble que nous devons
garder notre sérénité et notre plaisir
aussi de faire de la peau une question
importante également est ce que le poste
de premier secrétaire est liée au poste
de candidat à la présidentielle vous
êtes candidate si vous êtes élu au poste
de premier secrétaire obligatoirement
vous serai candidate à la présidentielle
est-ce que c'est lié je crois que ce qui
s'est passé lors de la précédente
élection présidentielle a prouvé qu'il
fallait une harmonie entre le principal
parti pour l'instant le parti
d'opposition et le candidat ou la
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
d'heure je crois que cet art se
mobilisent y ait un candidat pour la
présidentielle je pense que cette
harmonie et l'indispensable mais elle
n'est pas forcément un automatisme
merci beaucoup tout se mérite tout se
mérite merci beaucoup ségolène royal
juste une dernière question le livre de
bertrand delanoë sort cette semaine vous
allez le lire avec intérêt et oui j'aime
beaucoup les livres politiques donc oui
vous savez je n'ai aucun d'abord je n'ai
pas d'ennemi mois dans le parti
socialiste et je sais ça qui est
important ou savez la guerre des chefs
les militants n'en veulent pas et il n'y
en aura pas en tout cas vous n'entendrez
jamais dans ma bouche une quelconque
paroles désobligeantes à l'enjeu c'est
vrai que j'ai vu dans le texte que
bertrand de la noue elle signe avec
lionel jospin une certaine critique de
la démocratie participative
écoutez je la prends comme un élément du
débat d'idées et moi je défends
contraire cette idée que pour bien
dirigé que pour bien décidé que pour
bien gouverner avec volonté avec
détermination il faut d'abord avoir
écouté les citoyens et en l'occurrence
dans le cadre du congrès écouter les
militants merci beaucoup
ségolène royal des nouvelles de bernard
tapie dans l'actualité politique du
journal c'était devenu rare c'est en
tout cas un retour possible qu'il évoque
aujourd'hui chez nos confrères du
parisien
celui-ci n'exclut pas d'être candidat
aux élections européennes de 2009
s'estimant plus que jamais proche du prg
le parti radical de gauche
et puis enfin sachez que le nouveau
centre a tenu ce samedi son congrès à
nîmes lancé par les députés udf qui
avait rejoint nicolas sarkozy entre les
deux tours de la présidentielle le
nouveau centre a reconduit à sa tête le
ministre de la défense hervé morin
la question qu'on saute ce samedi
maintenant seriez vous prêt à acheter
votre prochaine voiture sur internet en
tout cas apparemment la méthode sûre et
économique les mandataires dispose de
remise parfois plus intéressante que les
concessionnaires à condition seulement
d'être tout de même vigilants mode
d'emploi avec fabien shadow et jean
francois monier en quelques clics sur
internet
joël meyer a trouvé la voiture de ses
rêves trois jours après l'avoir réservé
il vient prendre possession de son
véhicule un monospace haut de gamme
flambant neuf
son prix catalogue est de 53 mille euros
c'est un véhicule que j'ai que j'ai
acquis donc
trente cinq mille cinq cents euros donc
un petit peu à environ 17000 euros
d'économie 33 % moins cher parce que ce
sont des invendus les sites internet les
stocks dans des parkings comme celui ci
en région parisienne après les avoir
achetés aux concessionnaires
nous allons voir un concessionnaire et
nous lui proposons donc notre mode de
commercialisation directement sur
internet et de nous confier leurs stocks
et ensuite c'est stop on les met en
ligne et on sert d'intermédiaire
les concessionnaires ont en effet
intérêt à se débarrasser rapidement de
leurs stocks
quitte à les brader pour toucher des
primes de vente accordées par les
constructeurs acheter sa voiture sur
internet
l'idée fait son chemin en france l'an
dernier 30 mille automobilistes ont
franchi le pas ce qui représente 2 % des
ventes deux fois moins que les allemands
bien parti pour rattraper les américains
qui vendent 8% de leur voiture sur la
toile le succès de la vente en ligne a
fait réagir des constructeurs il propose
aussi désormais des ventes à prix cassés
sur internet
si vous venez sur un site de
constructeurs vous allez choisir votre
voiture vous allez partir sur vos
désiderata ce que voulaient les rangs
diesel en essence en 3 portes 5 portes
de quelques couleurs avec l option
sega c'est ça qu'on va pouvoir trouver
sur la largeur de notre site
et si ensuite ça pour lequel on va
rechercher la meilleure mine une
demi-douzaine de sites se partagent
aujourd'hui le marché les plus fiables
sont les plus visités
seul inconvénient sur la toile tous les
modèles de voitures ne sont pas toujours
disponibles
elle était depuis trop longtemps partie
à las vegas ne revenant en france que
pour quelques télévisions mais ses fans
français voulaient la retrouver sur
scène et bien dès lundi céline dion sera
de retour à bercy à paris tout d'abord
hier olivier les news high et mathieu
berden ont rencontré la star elle était
en concert à anvers regarder
de quoi vous
après cinq années passées à las vegas
elle a retrouvé son public
les oublions quelques secondes céline
dion et tournons la caméra en direction
des 16000 spectateurs
des larmes
et la communion avec l'idole
ce
elle a levé le voile sur son nouveau
spectacle 20 minutes seulement avant de
monter sur scène elle nous reçoit pas
une seconde à perdre
très professionnel la star aux 180
millions d'albums vendus
venez venez plus comme c'était que j'ai
à prouver à qui que ce soit que je peux
faire cette case je sais pas de faire
une carrière je sais pas de monter une
carrière je sais pas de d'avoir un
succès je veux qu avoir du plaisir
si le chien cheonan
mannheim plein après deux mandats sans
défaut
pour que tu m'aimes
le retour en france
c'est sûr que paris est un peu chez moi
alors mon retour à paris sur scène je
pense que quand je vois la boîte kalou 1
c'est un gros cadeau in turn your turn
ou y derrière la porte une télévision
allemande attend seulement une question
car show must go bonne le spectacle
n'attend pas quand on est debout quand
on est la reine
si oui oui
près des chiens
la page cinéma demain soir à 20h nous
seront exceptionnellement en direct de
cannes avec comme invités steven
spielberg
harrison ford et kate blanchett pour la
sortie du dernier opus des aventures d'
indiana jones
au coeur de ce quatrième volet une
étrange affaire de crâne de cristal une
légende fascinante
l'un de ces crânes est d'ailleurs exposé
au musée du quai branly à paris en ce
moment même alors mythe ou réalité
reportage jean françois cyr et et
raymond chape l'art la légende dit qu'un
crâne de cristal a été dérobé dans une
mythique cité perdue d'amazonie c'est le
secret le mieux gardé du moment après
quoi indiana jones peut-il bien courir
dans ces nouvelles aventures
apparemment un crâne de cristal aux
pouvoirs surnaturels qui vient dans son
but tout le monde veut le récupérer
où ça allait nous aider à le prouver
les scénaristes de steven spielberg ont
fusé dans l'imaginaire maya pour écrire
leur histoire
une légende raconte en effet qui
n'existe pas un mais treize crânes de
cristal a porté sur terre par les
atlantes 12 crâne ont été mises au jour
en reste un dernier à trouver vite car
toujours selon la légende
si tous sont revenus le 21 décembre 2012
ils délivreront un message à l'humanité
pierre marty fait partie de ceux qui y
croient
je ne rêve que d'une chose effectivement
ça pouvoir retrouver les treize crânes
de pouvoir les réunir et voir ce qu'ils
ont à les livrer comme message à
l'humanité
le musée du quai branly possède lui
aussi son crâne de cristal mais celui là
c'est bien rires
alors la puce il s'étale authentique il
est censé être des appels mais celui du
british muséum vient d'être daté du 19e
siècle et même peut-être failli en
allemagne selon les scientifiques
aucun peuple ancien avait la technique
pour façonner du cristal de roche
ces crânes aurait en fait été créés au
19e siècle par défaut serge amateurs
d'antiquités les innocenti qu il ait pas
il les pastèques
mais c'est une espèce de l'espace de
doute qui est qui est intéressant et qui
explique aussi que cet objet continue
d'exercer une fascination les crânes de
cristal une supercherie
réponse en 2012 ou peut-être demain sur
la croisette
et ce soir à cannes c'est un habitué qui
vient de monter les marches il s'agit de
woody allen le réalisateur américain
présente son 40e film avec penélope cruz
le titre vicky cristina barcelona
un film tourné justement bien loin de sa
ville de new york il a promené son
talent cette fois en espagne découverte
avec pascal deschamps et mickaël cariou
40 films 72 ans est toujours aussi
inspiré woody allen a depuis toujours le
don de bien s'entourer
flanqué de deux de ses actrices longues
comme des gens sans fin cet auteur
singulier suscite toujours le même
engouement du grand public
woody est ici hors compétition comme
d'habitude mais son premier film tourné
en espagne était précédé d'un buzz plus
que sulfureux sur le net les internautes
furent nombreux à consulter une bande
annonce sans dialogue avec quelques
scènes torrides et un baiser qu'aucun
entre scarlett et pénélope pour une
histoire d'amour à 4 à barcelone c'est
la première fois que l'on filmé des
scènes aussi torride
c'est quoi la prochaine étape un porno
en italie sacrifice humain de ce type
d'offre il ya une ambiance à barcelone
totalement différente de ce que je
connais pour un américain comme moi
c'est tellement exotique aux états unis
on est très coincé on a d'énormes
problèmes avec le sexe soit sec
woody allen ne joue pas dans son film
pour incarner le tombeur de ces dames il
a choisi le sublime javier bardem
absents de cannes
mais s'il était dans une galerie d'art
et que j'étais à côté de lui
c'est lui qui vous taperez dans l'oeil
mais audi a toujours été perçu comme un
charmeur et je suis sûr qu'il le sait
dommage en tout cas que vous dis n'est
pas souhaité être en compétition avec ce
film hilarant et profond à la fois qui a
emballé la croisette
voilà avant de terminer journal je vous
rappelle l'une des principales
informations de ce samedi ségolène royal
a confirmé ce soir sur ce plateau son
intention de briguer le poste de premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste un poste
on sait très convoitée elle affirmé
qu'elle n'avait pas d'ennemis au parti
socialiste avec le post le premier
secrétaire était indissociable de celui
de candidat à la présidentielle voilà
pour l'essentiel de l'actualité de ce
samedi
merci d'être fidèle à l'information sur
france 2 la météo donc avec isabelle
martinez 20h50 tenue de soirée présentée
par michel drucker en direct d'avignon
demain dès midi france de foot denis
balbir demain 13h olivier galzi je vous
retrouve demain soir à 20 heures depuis
cannes avec pour invités steven
spielberg et harrison ford très belle
soirée à gauche
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr
mais nous